well so many employers currently focused
on employee retention now might be the
best time to ask for a raise we have the
steps you need to take and advice for
women on why you want to do this sooner
rather than later
as an employee it really is time to go
to your employer and put your best
business case forward for a raise the
great resignation has employees moving
around all over the place kovit has
people looking for a better lifestyle
higher inflation and a labor shortage
really giving workers the upper hand
says career advisor rachel evans there's
something that your employer has on
their mind at the moment which is really
going to work in your favor she says you
may have leverage because your employer
doesn't want the hassle of replacing you
it's going to cost more than your
current annual salary if you leave and
they have to recruit
and retrain someone all over again to
come up to the standard that you were at
and that's the leverage that you have
right now compare salaries see what
someone is making in a similar role
within your company if you don't have
access to that information find out what
you're worth in the market put together
a business case
talk to your employer about your service
about how much you love working inside
the organization but how you believe you
are worth a little bit more and if
you're a female seeking a raise she adds
do it sooner rather than later for every
month you think i'm just gonna hold off
i might not quite have the courage to do
it yet
then you're actually robbing your future
self of additional retirement funds
and she explains it as such when it
comes to retirement women on average
have up to two million dollars less than
they've earned over their lifetime
compared to their male counterparts
christian